bonsoir nicolas à dainville merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous ce soir sur
rtl france vous faites partie des
signataires de cette lettre
emmanuel macron on s'en souvient avait
promis avant la crise de changer le
visage des quartiers d'ici à la fin du
quinquennat et pour vous donc la
promesse n'a pas été tenue
mais écoutez souvenez-vous du du rapport
borloo c'est à dire que à peine sorti il
a déjà été enterrés c'est un rapport
mort né et c'est vrai que nos quartiers
nos nos banlieues n'ont pas changé de
visage depuis l'élection d' emmanuel
macron loin de là il ya un certain
nombre de dispositifs auxquels les mères
avaient droit qu'il mobilisait et qui
ont été gelés je pense aux contrats
aidés qui étaient des contrats qui était
souvent utilisé par les pairs pour faire
face à tout un tas de de besoin aux
populations notamment des besoins
sociaux et on assiste aujourd'hui
effectivement une certaine bombe à
retardement à des territoires qui sont
en danger il ya une sorte de non
assistance à territoires en danger
puisque on fait face plus qu'ailleurs à
une augmentation du chômage de la
précarité des faillites des prestations
sociales
le rsa notamment qui qui coûte et qui
impacte très négativement tous nos
comptes municipaux et des collectivités
locales je pense notamment au
département et donc en conséquence vous
demander 1 % du plan de relance de 100
milliards d'euros soit 1 milliards
dédiés uniquement ou aux banlieues il
n'y avait aucune haine prévus dans ce
plan de relance pour ces territoires
effectivement c'est l'angle mort du plan
de relance
porté par emmanuel macron c'est qu'on a
effectivement des territoires qui semble
oublier et qui sont pourtant plus
impactée par la crise que que d'autres
territoires
je pense notamment à tout ce qui est de
l'ordre de la désertification médicale
on a aujourd'hui un manque de médecins
qui est vraiment très très durement
vécue par nos populations et donc si on
pouvait utiliser une partie de cet
argent du plan de relance pour
construire de nouvelles maisons
médicales
pour être attractif davantage auprès de
professionnels de soins
je pense que ce serait important un
autre exemple très concret moi dans mon
territoire de saint quentin en yvelines
on a un commissariat qui le commissariat
d'elancourt et qui est aujourd'hui dans
un état de délabrement terrible avec
honnêtement une véritable honte qui est
ressenti par les policiers quand ils
accueillent notamment les victimes
eh bien c'est la collectivité locale
l'agglomération et le département qui
aujourd'hui financent ce commissariat ce
nouveau commissariat
l'état répond aux abonnés absents donc
c'est c'est un drame que vivent beaucoup
de territoires de voir un désengagement
de l'état
je ne dis pas qu'il n'ya aucune mesure
prise par l'état
on peut avoir des adultes relais pour de
la médiation
on peut avoir de service civique pour
accompagner un certain nombre de
politiques publiques mais c'est une
goutte d'eau dans ce qu'il faudrait
mettre en place on attend des mesures
beaucoup plus massive en termes de
sécurité notamment pour rétablir la
tranquillité auquel les habitants de ces
quartiers ont tout de suite aussi droit
et vous parlez de sécurité vous parlez
de bombes à retardement concrètement que
craignez-vous bien c'est vrai que le
confinement on en parle beaucoup il est
je pense plus facile à vivre quand on a
une maison secondaire
mais quand on est dans des quartiers
très dense au 8e étage du tour dash-l m
c'est beaucoup plus dur à vivre et on
sent que ce confinement là il est
vraiment très durement très durement
vécue par les populations de ces
quartiers en particulier la sécurité où
on a un manque d'effectifs de police
nationale qui est aujourd'hui criant
donc on a vraiment besoin d'effectifs en
plus et puis sur des sujets très concret
on se sent nous les maires impuissants
je pense par exemple au rodéo vous savez
laisser ces fameux conduite de d'engins
à deux roues qui sont à la fois
dangereuse très insécurisant tu es qui
crée un peu comme monstre
un supporter là vraiment la vie des
habitants
les maires demandent plus de moyens
notamment des moyens innovants comme les
drones qui pourrait permettre de lutter
contre ce type contre ce type de
conduite
mais aujourd'hui on se voit opposer une
fin de non recevoir
on a l'impression qu'on a un système
juridique institutionnel sclérosé qui
n'arrivent pas à innover pour faire face
aux nouvelles formes de délinquance
on le voit sur les images à côté de vous
la vétusté aussi de certains logements
les les infrastructures finalement les
conséquences de ce confinement on l'a vu
c'est trop de personnes aussi qui vivent
à l'est les unes sur les autres
est-ce qu'il faudra revoir aussi la
politique urbaine selon vous bien sûr
moi je vous dis je suis élu donc maire
de la verrière
je suis aussi conseiller départemental
de trappes et attrapes comme à la
verrière cd souci permanent avec les
bailleurs des ascenseurs en panne des
problèmes de plomberie des pannes
d'électricité qui cause parfois des
incendies extrêmement dangereux pour nos
habitants des problèmes de chaudières
donc effectivement il ya un manque de
moyens il faudrait une grande
réhabilitation d'un certain nombre de
logements il faudrait aussi peut-être
revoir l'aménagement de certains
quartiers pour les rendre plus
accessibles avec les transports en
commun plus ouvert pour que les
commerces puissent s'y installer bref il
ya je pense à une ambition que qu'on
aurait dû fixer depuis le début du
mandat c'est une occasion qui est
manquée mais on garde espoir pour que
nos quartiers retrouve de l'attractivité
à l'intérieur des logements comme à
l'extérieur pour qu'on soit plus
attractif avec des médecins on a dit
avec des forces de l'ordre c'est très
important
avec également une vitalité de petits
commerçants qui sont aujourd'hui intact
et qui ne comprennent pas pourquoi ils
s'en servent pour 7 1 marquée par la
fermeture administrative
alors que les grandes plateformes en
ligne continue de vendre allègrement
tous les produits
bref on se sent oublié abandonné mais la
question de la vétusté elle est vraiment
centrale les halles temps je vous dis
moi avoir à la verrière dans ma ville
certains vivent avec des des cafards
avec des punaises
il ya des rats parfois au quai des tours
et c'est indigne indigne pour certains
de vivre dans de telles conditions très
court nicolas verdier finalement le plan
borloo
le gouvernement n'a absolument quasiment
rien retenu le plan borloo était une des
solutions tout n'était pas à prendre il
y avait effectivement un financement qui
était important mais il y avait des très
bonnes solutions en termes d'équité
urbaine en termes d'ascension sociale
avec la mesure d'une sorte de nerfs des
quartiers pour promouvoir aussi des
profils issus de ces quartiers pour
promouvoir des talents
c'est des territoires qui regorge de
talents mais aujourd'hui ils ont du mal
à être l'or à connaître l'ascension
qu'il mériterait donc on a vraiment un
besoin très fort et l'école l'école de
la république est très importante il
faut investir massivement avec des
outils innovants et peut-être des
renforts dans tout ce qui est soutien
scolaire soutien scolaire pour que les
jeunes puissent réussir dans deux
quartiers merci beaucoup nicolas
dainville évidemment c'est une vaste
question message entendu merci beaucoup
d'avoir répondu ce soir en direct à nos
questions sur ft france